good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the second live podcast webinar where
today I'm delighted to be joined by liam
thomas matt Collingwood's and kalpesh
boxy before very quickly before we go
into and the chaps just introducing
themselves to you all and two things so
firstly a huge part of today is gonna be
all about QA
I want to make sure that you get your
questions answered and a lot of you have
submitted questions and to register so
I've got loads of those up and ready to
ask these guys but as these guys are
speaking please feel free to submit
questions so it should be to the right
of you you should see a QA panel to the
right and you can very easily where it
says ask a question just type in there
and ask it and submit it and I'll make
sure that these guys can answer it and
if there's any questions that you really
like and then you can also click up vote
on the questions that you want to make
sure get answered and then the final
thing and all of you should know that
this podcast is sponsor supported by
hunted and hunted are really trying to
do their utmost in in challenging times
and they recently put together a a
survey that's completely dedicated to
business owners in recruitment and to
assess and gather information on how
businesses again through this tough
period so they've split into different
segments like impact on the market
evolving a people strategy remote
working infrastructure and I'm gonna
follow up with everyone and make sure
everyone gets that because the more
people that and obviously submit that
the more information they can share that
could hopefully benefit all of us so
before I start asking you guys some
questions one of you start introduction
and Liam if you go first if you could
just introduce yourself to everyone and
then we can get it started so Liam
Thomas co-founder of professional
solutions winning the recruitment
industry since 2002 running Highfield
for the last 13 years
we specialized in the built environment
space probably design
my project around the world very much
thank you Liam
and that afternoon all Matt Collingwood
I started my recruitment journey back in
1997 spent 17 years with one of the
largest corporates globally before
launching v'q in them in 2014 all right
so we've got two offices Southampton and
burn again focusing on an IT when I'm
not doing the day job with we're joining
thank you I I remember of Canaries which
is a group professional IT recruiters in
um in in Birmingham
nice kalpesh hi everyone so my name is
Kyle Busch maxi like man I joined I
start off recruitment in 1997 working
for s3 so I've done pretty much every
mark here I'm a permanent contract guy
so hopefully we can add variety on the
panel to help you guys out and look what
I'm grateful about the podcast paid for
is it's our chance to help you guys out
and to help each other in this uncertain
time cool thank you guys well honestly
pleasure having you so I think safe to
say all of you combined of works and
recruitment way longer than I've been
alive I think that I think no one has I
mean a lot of the workforce would
definitely not have experience of the
adversity in and sort of challenges were
going through right now and but where I
wanted to start with you guys is so
besides the current situation and climb
at today like what's been sort of the
most challenging time for you guys's
recruitment business owners or work in
the s3 and and how did you get through
it want to feel free want to view to go
so I think no no yeah gone Liam
okay so obviously you know probably what
most people are thinking about credit
crunch in 2008 we were quite fortunate
because it was just me my business
partner Sam at that time we'd literally
just started to take people on and you
started your business in a way where a
year before you know but by the time we
really got going you know we've made
some good headway and then
I think it was kind of June July in this
summer of 2008 when it really hit when
Lehman Brothers went down okay for our
sector working in just UK kind of built
environment then it was logs already
turned off a tap so it was quite scary
to young relatively inexperienced
contract recruitment consultants at that
time we thought we're very good at our
jobs and we were good at filling jobs
but we weren't necessarily the best
business owners in the world so it was a
good time for us to learn and kind of
you know car teeth really in dealing
with problems you know similar to that
were going through at the moment under
the surface of water so how did you feel
that you got free and that's that
difficult period well the first thing
that happened is you kind of go into
shock you're like wow this doesn't
happen before what should you do and
then you just need to sort of sit down
and you can't keep thinking the way
you've always thought so thinking about
new strategies in new ways how are you
going to generate income innovation
exactly you just can't keep doing the
same thing and you know when the markets
change expect the same results you've
got to think outside the box and for us
it was looking globally and we moved a
lot of our business to to Asia in the
Middle East and ended up doubling our
turnover for the last recession so
people that work well for us think
another box
yeah definitely yeah you've just got to
change really you can't keep thinking
about the same thing sit down get go
somewhere quiet get you know some of
your senior people around you and have a
bit of brainstorm hopefully people have
got quiet places in their homes now Matt
what about you what's been the toughest
time for you and how did you get for it
did you say I suppose you know the
toughest times or the biggest challenge
and this is whether you know you when we
started out when we were highest growth
and even today's just around cash flow
yeah so it's just been on top and
knowing what you know you cash cash flow
forecasts been on top of chasing any age
debt looking back it kind of and this is
going back 2000 recession the 2008 2010
double-dip recession where we have bad
debt so where companies that went bust
ceased trading you can't recover that
usually when the creditors go in there's
a little work it's very little for the
for the creditors and the fact is
businesses are going to go bust or they
are going to have cash flow issues and
that's going to affect the whole supply
chain so one of the things that we'd be
doing very very closely he's he's
working with our customers would be
working with suppliers around payment
terms etc just so we can you know we've
got a cash flow in the bills our bills
paid etc but I think that those are
problems that start ups going to
experience that cash flowing when
businesses are going through super
growth because a lot of the time you
might be groaning I'm doing really well
but when your money's tied up in someone
else's bank accounts it can restrict you
growth okay and kalpesh what about for
you what office lis work an s3 for a
good number of years what what was some
of the most challenging times for you
before this period and how did you get
through it
so I've got like Matt and I've been
through two two downturns two upturn so
I did the post y2k 9/11 crash which just
completely came overnight and then
obviously post Lehman Brothers and the
key thing for me so I've worked in a
private company and I've worked in a
public company you know in terms of both
of those barriers and I think the cash
flow absolutely I think Liam's point
about thinking outside the box
absolutely the biggest thing for me was
about making sure you're doing adapt so
the market required the rule book that
you would have had in a boom market will
not be fit for today so the key theme
for today is you've got that what you do
as a business you've got to make sure
your people know where you're going with
a plan and I think the most important
thing I'd say to everyone is that you
know there are still people buying out
there there will still people actually
taking on that services but you just
can't find a way to connect with them
and make sure they see the value you can
offer okay interesting so just just
before I start going through the quite a
lot of questions that people submitted
them just to saw set the scene and to
give everyone context on sort of where
you guys are today so Liam let you start
of you again so right now today
see as a business over the last couple
of weeks what of like what they look
like and what where's your sort of
business at today just to set the scene
for everyone just to give a bit of
context of the types of businesses that
you run so yeah so we're based in based
in Hampshire single site agency about 40
of us in there and it's been quite good
so you know wonder benefits being a
single site it's just the key for us is
just be keeping that communication on
point they'll be really important you
know everyone's worried at the moment so
the last few weeks have just really for
me being putting an arm around everyone
you know everyone's panicking at the
moment they want some reassurance so
it's just been that communication it's
been key for the last couple of weeks
definitely and what was been what's been
the most difficult decision you had to
make so far then probably Wow the
nervousness of looking at the cash flow
like matt says you know you think you
think you're in a good position but
until you really see it on paper you
know it's it's you've got to basically
decisions on that really so we haven't
had to making me too lucky we haven't
had to make too many tough decisions
probably the hardest thing for me is you
tell them my kids will not going to
Disneyland so at the moment I think ya
know so I was just gonna sorry to jump
in there but and we were speaking about
this before we went live and Chris you
just put down know that we were talking
about that you're sort of you've got a
cash flow plan of six months how many i
just wants me oh yeah yeah we've we've
sort of split the cash flow and the
income right back
worst-case scenario you know forecasted
for six months and you know it doesn't
doesn't look great but yeah you
forecasted cash flow as six months and
then also you're gonna constantly
evaluate that I'm sure okay yeah Matt
what about you what what is today look
like with your business you might
remember when we we did our podcast
together once things right spoke about
our industry when recruiters tend to get
together certainly recruiting leaders
and owners the numbers the metrics they
talk about the size of their businesses
yeah number of staff and the phrase I
used at the time you staff numbers are
often vanity the sanitary realese it's
the bottom line and I
think that this is a great example of
what high numbers of staff can do to a
business we kept thank you pretty lean
so there's only 22 of us and when
co-leads finished the week 22 of us I
kind of wanted to make a very clear
message across the business that we put
our on Joe and everyone we're going to
back then we haven't got rid of anyone
we haven't following anyone
there's been no reduction of salons or
anything like that we are asked the guys
to compromise a little bit perhaps with
their with their holiday just because we
don't necessarily think there's a full
requirement there for people working
five days a week but really good show
just like what lay a man and Calpol she
said we've done a cash flow forecast for
for six months so yeah you've given
months as well like earlier it's a
rolling six months so in a month's time
they'll be six months in a month after
that would be will be six months yeah
one of the things that we're looking at
as well just just in terms of where
we're at today I think it's really
important that we can be we can be agile
and we know exactly where obviously so
we're heavy on contract okay ninety
percent of our businesses contract so
we're getting regular timesheet reports
and we can look at contractors and know
that on site it's one thing thinking you
might have 100 contractors but if only
20 of those guys are working it's
quickly going to catch up catch up with
you you know in terms of your cash flow
okay so you've been keeping them on that
on hum yeah how many okay that's
interested in and then just to frame
that so liam is well your business
what's the split in contracts and palm
just for everyone's context at the
moment it's probably close to their
50/50 but yeah we're aiming for its me
70/30 in favor of in favor contract
contract okay cool and then the kalpesh
I know that you've been obviously left
us free in December but you you've been
really active in having conversations
offering help so what would have been
the conversations you've been having
with different business owners and and
so what's been the common themes that
you've heard from people as to what
today looks like for them and what
they're currently thinking about so my
conversations have been completely
varied and I tend to I've spoken to
organizations from naught to 5 people
right the way through 200 hundred people
plus companies and I think and I want to
pick up on
the man talked about vanity insanity
yeah right now look the number-one thing
is if you're a leader it's time to lead
that's probably the starting point I
have a conversation anyone the world
doesn't need more directors and managers
sitting in a room somewhere or not
talking to anyone if you are a leader of
a business and a recruitment business
specifically it is time to lead and
leadership to me means two things one
you have to get in front of your
customers and talk to your customers
don't leave it to your salespeople they
need to be to know you're going in the
battle with them as well and the second
thing is you have to make sure you're
making the right decisions for the
business and part of being a leader is
sometimes you've got to make the
unpopular ones as well right so the two
things I tell everyone is agility
responsiveness you need to know how you
can move and what you can respond to
yeah you need to make sure you've got a
plan and I love caviar that with a clear
plan make sure you communicate it and
you get the right people involved and
the thing I've learned and I'm not just
talking about you know mark is hopping
down the thing I've learnt in general
crisis situations in my life work and
non-work is some people thrive in a
crisis and it might be the people you
least expect to so in your teens and in
your squad look at those people that
you've got that you think you know what
they might be the most junior person or
why time served or Billings or whatever
it might be but they might be out add
the most value to you right now because
they've got the right metal when the
right now look to help them yeah and the
final one is Cashman and I'm at two
talked about at the absorber you've got
to know your numbers yeah you cannot
outsource knowing the numbers today and
I was talking to an organization last
week every day they have a cash position
report coming out right I call about the
toilet of doomsday scenario the doomsday
scenario is no one buys any more from
you no one spends any more money with
you what does that mean then you also
need to know what levers you've got twin
backpack okay cool so all right so let's
sort of segue into some of the questions
that people have so I think with what
you just send that about leading and
and all of that carpe so I think and
we're talking about this before we went
live the the working from home right so
I think a lot of people now and um
selenium you're at home Matt you're at
home you're now having to lead away from
your typical home right which is your
office and and your culture in your
environment so just just to set and I
think this this then goes into like
Mike's question on how to onboard people
and like so for you guys how how are you
now communicating with your business
like what what have you set up and what
does a typical day look like for you
guys and one in your business making
sure that you're you're leading from
your home like at first then yeah yeah I
think it's it's fair to say I think we
come from a generation where as
recruiters we were in at 7:30 I think if
were left before center in an evening
need to be getting the death stare from
the boss but I think things have changed
one of the things that we've been slow
to adapt to is home working because this
is really open my eyes I think one of
the key things in order for it to work
what managers got abs just have complete
trust in their staff firstly yeah I have
massive trusting those guys and to be
fair to him we're gonna be home working
for this week but the results are there
and it will be something that will be
consider as doing something longer-term
when Kobe 19's took over nineteen is
long gone and one of the things we are
doing this is just to kind of keep that
rapport going and communication is we're
having a huddle 8:30 every morning we
have one in the middle of the day one at
the end of the day like I'm on two odd
row so those that aren't aware it's
video platform you get multiple people
on there you can share screen somebody
it's absolutely brilliant for for
interviewing as well as bringing all
year or you colleagues together so it's
having that regular regular comms
keeping those guys positive throughout
they're keeping the message consistent
across the offices just in terms of in
terms of what we're doing they don't
know this yet but I want to sprinkle in
a bit of fun with it just a range of
personal trainer
really especially so
to do to get out yeah yes oh you've got
free touchpoints morning in the mid of
the day later in the day and then also
now you're like right how can we have
fun with this and try and yeah breed
that sort of team morale with things
like that
Liam what you doing how are you
communicating to your stuff cause how
because as you said you have circa 40
staff but how are you ensuring that
you're communicating to these people
yeah I think that's the key word as well
communication it's that's the bit for me
personally because you know I don't see
in an office I'm seen with everyone else
and I'd be find it hard being isolated
at home so pretty much exactly what Matt
said you know make sure you on the video
calls of everyone keeping those going
but we found slack absolutely brilliant
for anyone who's not using it yes that's
a subject all it means making sure you
know it's because it's not business as
usual at the moment you know you need to
try and inject a bit of fun in it when
you were working remotely so any
positive news you get makes really
shouting about it even if it's just
qualifying a really good vacancy getting
some good Seabees over interviews
whatever share share that positivity the
smells are bright they're Gwynn's yeah
definitely because everyone will bounce
off that and give you something to smile
about and also at home yeah so and so
with this then obviously a lot of people
happen to use video or drug zoom
Microsoft teams whatever it may be like
so let I'd love to get your thoughts on
Mike a meses question I don't know if
any of you guys have come up against
this right so a lot of people are now
having to do interviews I have a video
doing it remotely and that's but the
part that's going to be difficult for
businesses is they've never had like if
you guys took on a new recruiter
tomorrow that you're gonna have to do
that from yeah from home and you're
gonna have to unboard them remotely so
how how can you how have you gone about
or how have you heard your consultants
deal with this or come combat of how
we're gonna get these people on board
it's our business when we're on lockdown
and they can't come into the office meet
the guys like what have you heard from
if you've heard it directly from clients
or from some your concerns have got on
the phones how our clients onboarding
people and how people approach that
we've done we've onboarding two guys
this week so okay we've got a client in
the finance sector we've arranged the
laptops to be sent out to these guys we
can get them on board to get them
started so it is still possible
I've only yet every client is going to
do that I think the smart ones will want
to get a competitive edge at the moment
so why would you not want to be
interviewing these guys and knocking
them down now we're here more clients
are putting things on ice but have you
done that before Matt so how have you
approached it because I'm sure that
isn't so you haven't had to unboard
people remotely it's so how have you
yeah have you what have you actually
done to ensure that that happens we've
actually never needed to
we've never been in this situation this
this massive shortage of hardware a
moment so really you've got a you quite
unable to find a hardware supplier or
you've got to be able to do that get
those machines all imaged and get them
sent out but 4G at the moment those
businesses are still operating and
there's delivery guys still dropping
kids off so I think at the moment is
still a possibility again coming back to
what they've said what I think both of
our business is a contract late so these
guys probably don't need bigger
induction the purpose that might need
fair enough and little limb if you what
having real concerns come up like come
up against that or yeah so we you know
part of the the objectives you know
we're sitting guys a slightly different
KPIs at the moment when they're speaking
to people you know one of the things
we're talking about is not you know for
jobs can we feel about how can we help
you
and I think video interview I've had
more it's pretty common now so a lot of
people have been doing that anyway so
it's not that unfamiliar for people you
know really good question for Mike is
the onboarding part of people juggling
with so when we realize that we actually
put a bit of content out on a guide on
how to remotely onboard people okay yeah
we've been sharing that with our clients
and that's been quite helpful to some
really good check out there at the
moment you know there's stuff like
Charlie hey char which is really good
software warning people you can do it or
remotely and it's taking advantages of
the tools that we've got now in this
this digital age and my
ensure our clients are all aware of it
really yeah and I think obviously I
think from a lot of conversations I've
had generally that onboarding piece is
genuine are generally an opportunity as
a recruitment business to add like
significant value on that and be
involved and heavily involved on
onboarding these new people so on that
note then I think you just mentioned
there Liam I'd love to get your thoughts
as well kalpesh like a lot of people
when they were submitting questions said
like like how do we approach BD right
now like what with with the current with
what's going on right now what like how
should people be take like approaching
business development what your thoughts
on that
feel free someone you think again this
is the conversations I'm having with
different the first thing is you have to
accept what's going on the world and
people will be feeling at different
points of emotions when you appear
trying to get through to them but I
think you can still put causing and and
might might typically the starting point
would be start with your warm list start
with the people that buy from you start
with the people you've engaged with
don't start with a cold cause think
about how you're going to connect with
them as well because not everyone wants
to talk on the telephone right now you
know we've just been talking about how
to use technology so is it slack is it
Google Hangouts is it is interview you
can get on thin terms of a domain or et
cetera but I think you can still put
calls in and you should still have
conversations and I know again talk to a
company this morning there's a lot of
people now get in Corona fatigue you
know we're off two weeks in threes
right people are bored they've bought
about are talking about it so they're
looking for a bit of escapism as well
put the calls in but just be mindful of
the person you're talking to be clear
about why you're calling them up look I
just know we're a real thick skin if
people don't want to talk to you right
now don't take it personally come back
to it and they walk away and company may
call back in for the future but you
there are different ways of connecting
with people it's not just telephone yeah
there's enough online events going on
there's things like this you're going on
in a number of different forums right
now
but I think you can still do it and
learn from my own personal experience no
my best times have actually been in hard
markets okay
the difference with this market as
opposed to 2008-2009 it's not man-made
if everyone has gone through it so you
have to be respectful and mindful of
where people are in image and the
emotional journey they're on at the
moment so it's a peer but you you like
you'd like to think people would welcome
a conversation isn't just focused on
coronavirus but you've got to be
empathetic be mindful and yet see how
you can help what what about you guys
leave I'm at like I wouldn't you tend to
your guys how important to be at
business development right now and like
what's how they're approaching it I
think to cut yeah you wouldn't even
necessarily term it business development
at the moment it's keep and contact with
your clients and just speaking to them
the end of the objective at the moment
isn't just sales thinking the wrong
feeling jobs is brilliant at the moment
and there are jobs out there but you
know embassies are great where
Compassion's are great word that's what
we've been talking about in the office
and it's it's like how I says everyone's
going through the same problems at the
moment so it's understanding those and
sharing empathy and yeah you can help if
you can help them out with something
like you know a remote onboarding plan
and how to do it then you know they're
going to remember you when they do need
those jobs filling in the future you
know they're they're going to be the
ones that remember you for helping them
times are tough okay
Matt and if in to add to that or just
yeah yeah I think from the beady side
issues second the right sort of
expectations
I got Russell Monday and if you know
he's a coach trainer he's done a bit of
work with a few my guys recently and
rather than setting the expectation of
you've got to go and think of jobs and
all the way of it and that is their
mindset I've got to get a job and get
the pressure off at the moment we second
the expectation more around building no
side lists okay lead generation funny
out where these guys have gone who they
worked for so the real basic so BD
doesn't necessarily mean the KPI pulling
requirement it could be a lot more and I
think we need to remove any of the we
can't be setting these guys or setting
an expectation they all should be going
out putting jobs because they won't
deliver on that and it's it's like a job
very negative yeah so what so with that
then what should wash
anyone that's obviously watching that
how is managing the team remotely right
now is being the leader what what what
are you guys emphasizing that your guys
do this usually mentioned a bit there
Matt in terms of save less and leaves
etc but like what for anyone again we
haven't been through this a lot of
people haven't had to manage their team
remotely what [ __ ] what are you guys are
emphasizing or what what KPIs in this
climate should your guys you making sure
you guys focus on if it's not the
typical things obviously so on the
contract market
you know we've got them around at the
moment speaking to every single contract
that we have and really really focusing
down and doubling down on that
contractor care really making sure that
all okay you know they've got any
queries you know if some of them are on
temporary layoffs just making sure
they've got all the good advice you know
just looking after advising some of them
on the way about mortgage payments and
the holidays you can take and things
like that so it's not all about sale
sale sale at the moment it's about
looking after your contractors and your
clients as well at this time so
obviously you know it's important that
we get as much the contractor book
working as we possibly can at the moment
so you know make it to all those figures
of all kind of up to date as well so you
know what's going to be coming in every
week on the the contracted payroll side
okay so you're just looking at just as
many touch points as possible with their
existing network and relationships yeah
definitely okay
what about you Matt what thing and I
know you're just talking about how yeah
the change your expectation which I love
that anything that you are also
emphasizing your guys to focus on to
ensure that doing the right activities
yeah if we're having sales calls with
clients that just need to be educated
educated calls yeah the point in talking
to clients about when they make is going
to be hiring but we can have
conversations with them about how
they're getting their workforce mobile
what's their business continuity plan
what's a disaster recovery what are they
going to do in the event that 30 percent
of their IT department they're going to
be often and those are the the
opportunities where we can backfill
those pretty quickly we contractors we
have seen but firms taking a lot of
contractors on recently simply to do
those roles and get their people mobile
and to protect their business you know
it's your question the other thing
targets just to get more out of them
candidates and Lina says contractors its
what an amazing opportunity that we've
got the moment to get through to these
people win it all at home their boss
isn't around they can take these calls
and probably a lot of the time they're
probably welcome a bit of interaction
you know as all of us are working from
moment to moment my bar partners around
or families but it's gonna really a bit
lonely and we're only it we add a tune
for some of us oh my god great
opportunity for our recruiters to have
those have those conversations so I'd
say it's educating calls to our clients
the stuff that's relevant to them okay
and just and talk to our people to talk
to and and get as close as possible to
candidates and contracts now I love that
guys and I think just and then someone's
a nothing on the flip side of this which
you have to do to lead that as a manager
like someone submitted a question which
I thought was really interesting so like
now with this remotely like how would
you recommend managers leaders challenge
output whilst working from home without
being a big bother or doing it in a
negative way or whatever because I think
that's also the challenge isn't it like
it's great if people do that but what
I've been known you've what people
aren't doing that like how can you
challenge that would you think about
that I think you changed somewhat yeah
so just as you would in the office or a
normal just yeah you have to do it in
there remotely so one of the things I
guess just to be mindful on that is we
talked early about kind of motivating
people and they're all kind of
positivity thing we're at ageism and I
think as this goes on in everything
we're all do four weeks yeah could even
be months we're gonna have some people
who are going to be maybe isolated or
working on the on their own and the
research is a mental health issue here
to continue so although the activity
levels for simply for my drop it's not
because
they're been lazy my just me they're not
in the boy mind at the moment or the
right place and I think that those are
sorts of people that you know we we have
a word when we need to but it's
understanding that people that might be
not in there in the best place yeah even
the support they need
yeah Liam or Gina so sorry I think it's
like you know like Matt says really it's
just not assuming anything make those
expectations really crystal clear at the
star but then if people do have a
problem with them you know you make sure
you ask the question why you know a lot
of people because they're in a different
environment people are going to struggle
for different reasons be there you know
mental health or you know not like in
the isolation or the fact they've got
three or four kids running around all
day and they can't actually do any works
okay and it's just understanding it's a
different situation for everyone again
and bit of empathy bit of compassion and
just keep those communication lines open
but you know I completely agree with
Matt you've got to make those
expectations clear you know it's easier
to talk to people at the moment so where
those activity levels should be on the
rise if anything so yeah and I think
let's definitely I've got quite a few
questions on mental health and things
like that and resilient and getting
through this because it's a lot for me
personally but I I'm find it really
difficult like definitely I'm so my I've
moved down to Eastbourne with my
girlfriend's family my girlfriend's mum
yes as I start showing symptoms so she's
now got a self isolate and I can't leave
the house for 14 days and honestly my
head fell off last night oh my god so
like what and no doubt a lot of people
were gonna find the challenging like
definitely mentally so like what one of
the questions was one is it the managers
responsibility to monitor people's
mental well-being I'd love to think it
is but like what are you guys doing to
ensure that I don't know but people feel
safe to talk about the mentally the
challenging side of this what you didn't
guys doing to make sure that these
people are able to talk about or trying
to impact that or help with that what
comes up for you grateful we're
fortunate enough that we've got a really
amazing like mental health trained
professional in the on the team in it so
we're
yeah yeah yeah he was of course he was
really passionate about it and he's he's
literally exactly the sort of person
you'd want to do that job so we've put
him through the course and yeah he's
he's great too
great to talk to about anything like
that so everyone knows if we're in the
office were out of the office you know
they've always got access to him and you
know it's still worthy stage disposal
working remotely at the moment but next
week we've got plans to really really
roll that out and you know get him
assisting people and kind of being
proactive with it wife then when people
come to him yeah so you're gonna make it
communicative on there in fact if anyone
doesn't have booking time or virtual
coffee or whatever they can do that with
the person you have internally yeah
definitely just being you know and
almost you know he might not
he's probably got enough on his plate at
the moment but almost I'm gonna I'm
going to ask him to kind of check in
with people individually and just make
sure they're doing okay because you know
some people be struggle to put their
hand up sometimes and they just need
that question asked every now and again
yeah that's fair enough
what about you you either kalpesh or and
that like was what some of the things
that evoke are pleasurable hearing or
Matt your mate I know you mentioned the
PT session which no doubt is part of
this but anything you're doing to ensure
that the men like you've done as much as
you can for your guys on the mental side
to support them through this I think
something like this really should be in
a business right from the early days you
shouldn't take a situation like this for
people to start thinking about it I just
come back to the word we'll mention a
couple of times already it's just
communication yeah if someone isn't in
the right place they need to raise the
hands we can support them as best we can
I think there's a lot of really good
consultants and third parties out there
so I love what name's Tony tend to get
so when in his business there are two
open there's external people as well but
that can be used and I just think the
nature of where we find ourselves alone
doing all this fire webcams etc a lot of
these guys could be booked out for an
hour to do a level of support or
coaching business business coaches or
mental health specialists yeah to help
out so I'd say to anyone if they feel
that they've got those challenge used to
raise their hands I think if they're at
the same time as well you know we've got
to think of our own mental
yeah it was a lot of us at our level
that are carrying no not only our own
livelihood the livelihoods of twenty
fifty or hundred staff and their
families so I think it's important that
we can talk and it's good to talk to it
to a peer group so you know the most
recruitment owners are going to be in
the same boat so they keep it is I'd
start reaching out and talking to as
many of those people as you know support
so I mentioned earlier needs a bit of a
plug anyway but our Canaries group we've
got 50 members and we've got oh what's
that group that I guarantee we get in 50
odd messages a day from owners that want
to share a bit of success they've got
challenged they've got what they've
heard government releases about the
grants and stuff like that now we're
quite fortunate that we've been groups
me and go now for for two and a half
years and it's a real success but I
think for those that aren't in a group
whether it's CRN or or APSCo or whatever
it's just find another local recruitment
owner reach at no really yeah after I
said before on my podcast you get
recruiters together and they do me say
yeah he's going well and we do amazingly
well well this is one of those chances
just brutally honest about yeah yes if
you if you're a business owner right now
or leave the fill in the loan make sure
you reach out to people and kalpesh what
are you hearing from the people you're
speaking to on on helping yeah the
conversation how many people get to help
get through this mentally and then the
challenge is they're talking about it
right so number one I'm gonna start with
the leader yeah Matt just talked about
and there's two Canaries or whoever
you've got in your your world that you
go to has a leader make sure you have
got an outlet in this as well because
your mental health is absolutely
critical to be able to be there to
support your business and I think you
like one of the things I'm learning and
I'm quite lucky at the moment I'm
talking to people in random places about
random things and it doesn't have to be
someone from recruitment it could be
someone completely random you know so
please make sure you make that time for
yourselves I think if you're a leader
it's critical
second thing around me is there are so
many different experts out there I'm not
gonna name check anyone for fear of
upsetting anyone but there are people
with a crewman experience to understand
what we go for is pressures thank me
there to support you see if you don't
have the luxury of Liam and what he's
got with someone internally going points
only it's probably one best money you
will spend right now yeah people and
then the final thing I mean the people
are there is that this is I go back to
the point about being good leaders Ryan
if you see it changing someone's
behavior and I appreciate a little bit
harder when you're trying to do it down
slack or interview or zoom or one of
those type of platforms if someone's
gone quiet on you there's there's a
problem right yeah if someone or
something is quite an introvert is
talking really really loud there's a
problem the expert go and solve it you
just need to know there might be
something that teams just to take
someone in so you don't help them and I
think the final thing I'd say is look
we're all in this together right so this
is the world of frenemies if you want to
think of anything so if you're always
about taking your competitor down
against on the job today is not about
worrying about that yeah Matt's point
and Liam's point as well is just don't
put a call in yeah and for the same
challenges and you never know you're
cool my age you'd be appreciated by
someone else as well yeah no I like that
and cool right let's make sure we get
some of these questions answered then so
talk question right now will was asked
if you're a concern in this climate who
has seen all their jobs put on hold and
previously fruitful clients put on
recruitment freezes how would you go
about building their business right now
that that's that's tough what would you
think about that I mean what my view on
this will I don't think there's a magic
tree out there you're not going to turn
a corner and find it a bunch of jobs and
everyone's in the same boat is that
there is still some business out there
like I said I'd be going after things
that are relevant
you know retail seems to be doing what
is in the shops and mobility disaster
recovery certainly within from within an
IT perspective contract as well it's
it's possible that I don't know Willy
Wilz a firm guy that you
back to those clients and asks about
what contractors they've taken on or
what particular time would they need to
take additional resource on okay into
and anything else to add kalpesh what do
you think about that what how could
someone go about you said you've had a
lot of success in hard markets what how
could someone go about rebuilding some
more opportunities to make money my
starting point would be to always
thought okay and I don't know how long
you've been a criminal with your promo
contract but look the starting point is
you always start off in a warmest place
possible and then go out to being in the
coldest place so if you stop moving
system customers whether it's candles
with clients and start working out from
that Network that's one way out of doing
it the second way around is exactly what
Matt said find the hot industry so if
you think that right now no people
medical device companies engineering
companies right any company right now
around beta to go and make good informed
decisions
hey is becoming mainstream and I think
with my I found a use for a I finally
you know in terms of trying to help us
map out some of these coded trends
coming through facilities you know there
are people that if you think about
pop-up hospitals there's some
infrastructure logistics of industries
out there that are mission critical
right now and I don't underplay that
that will still need people and they're
people yeah they're gonna try and do
themselves and that's fine that happens
in boom markers as well but you know
what there's definitely opportunities
and the big thing I'd say to well is if
you if you're working as part of a team
or you you know you're you've got a
leader above you go and talk to your
leader
don't ask questions and also reset what
the expectations are on you for the next
week two three four weeks as you build
up your business again yeah um okay next
question Chris stringer so what so maybe
but obviously and Matt like what what
what dead tree obviously he said is what
days are using to forecast for the next
quarter fairly unique situation so are
there any barometers that you would use
to forecast outside of current runners
like what how do you think about that
what what what this all data points your
you guys are looking at
I've constantly so I think you know from
our side of it you've got to look at the
markets you're in and the sectors you're
in which one of those are going to be
busy and how I'd dial are you how can
you read a poor your staff internally to
make sure you're focusing on those
markets are going to be busier and then
obviously base your four cows around
that firms gonna see a bigger hit in the
in the short term than contract we're
quite fortunate in a lot of sectors we
work out that you know most of the
contractors we have are still working so
that's obviously good news for us but
it's how can we then exploit those
opportunities and make sure we're still
friends where you know the market is
busy so for us it's gonna be definitely
perm taking a pretty heavy here and
contract will definitely be down but you
know not as much as perm to give an
exact trigger I don't think anyone knows
where it is such a unique situation but
you know the what we always do is plan
for the worst and hope for the best
really well how love you blood Pam wise
what have you played like what have you
put in your six months and plan for them
life so you do you know when you do a
cash flow forecast you you put different
amounts of perm in there you know yeah
well the worst ones off c0 but you know
I think it's good to know you know if
you if you have a cash flow forecast
we've got zero perm coming in what
didn't you know what yeah yeah at least
you know everything's a bonus on that
and then you know varying various
amounts twenty percent above that forty
percent than sixty and onwards from
there so okay you've got a map you've
got a map out different scenarios and
you know make sure math spoke about you
know cash been king earlier and you can
see how long you can hold out in this
period if things go bad for a longer
period that we all hope man different
add to that I know Chris so he's got a
amazing business predominantly within
the the poem space around the around the
forecasting he's going to be difficult
with with as Liam said it's it's going
to be closer to the zero mark it's going
to be blunt over next couple of months
in terms and what we sell in terms of
what we do is around forecast at the
moment because we are waiting more
towards contract he does make it easier
and we've got as I make
the beginning of podcast we've got a we
now have a report that comes out every
single week so I'm looking unable to
tell which my contract isn't working
we're keeping regular contact with them
just picking up on what
kalpesh said and probably this would be
for a Chris would be if you are at perm
heavy business start talking be to your
warm clients start talking to them about
their contractor usage and under what
circumstances they would because if you
start seeing signs or they give you
those opportunities you can forecast
better on on contract me give you some
growth okay interest in and just on that
before Rob's question came through which
I want you guys in a sec quiet yeah how
I saw I've had this myself was asked a
couple of weeks like how how do you go
about some Mike's question on how did
you chase their clients were probably
inclining towards keeping cash in their
bank accounts I mean sales calls feel a
bit weird but chasing for money must
feel bit even with this like what should
people be doing that I don't know what
should people be chasing they're exactly
that yeah maybe no names when I worked
at a corporate business one of our
customers went bust I mean they were a
huge company and then the bad debt was
massive and I got to know the accounts
payable person I had a conversation with
her afterwards and she said Matt we're
in a difficult position towards the end
and we paid the smaller businesses first
because we knew the impact it would have
the big corporate were at the bottom of
the list know whether that's right or
wrong legal or not I don't know but I
think that if the reason going to be any
bad debts or cancer in that situation I
think we as the directors this is why
kalpesh said about the the the business
owners talking to these people we should
be talking to their the head of Finance
for these businesses and stressing we
are we are small companies with
privately owned and we need them to one
of the payment terms can we force them
to make payments to us I don't think we
can I don't there so think this is the
time to be issuing legal notice you to
them and Chinese Brenda like pain
attacks and all the rest of it and I'll
probably remember those agencies that
can afford
to give them payment terms and support
them with that yeah I'm car but I put
you saved it want one last point as well
just on a Mike's point is often when we
look at the depth it's outstanding we
look at our client or I think it's
really important to look at the supply
chain so if our clients paid by their
customer who's there in custom and how
volatile is the industry that they work
in yeah interesting
kalpesh anything to add I think it's to
pacing back if I can just go back to the
previous question really briefly for
Chris as well about perm so there's two
one thing you can do on Perman and look
I wouldn't use it as your absolute tool
right now but keeping in your locker
right so if you know where we're going
over the next couple of weeks and things
will start to become clear awfully
anyway but there's no harming you've
been out to go to your best customers
and say look right pay me a retainer for
future business once things start
getting good if you know when people
gonna turn around again
and start hiring there's no harm in you
actually doing the prepaid sale right
for future business pay me now
and you might have to be flexible right
to get someone to give you any money
upfront
but that might help you out with your
cash flow in a period where it's it's
lower or in decline and it might mean
that when you come out with the other
end you've got to do business a little
bit cheaper in terms of placements but
at least you've got you out of the
autumn it also gives you a reason to
stop pipelining and building Candida
pools for opportunities that you know
will be coming back as well right
rolling that classic oh I might have a
job coming up it's now you're actually
building stuff for something this
particular and the same old pretend goes
with contract as well the bit around
cash flow I think you'd look this goes
back to you have to put the calls in you
know people are expecting these phone
calls think about what you do in your
personal life if you are struggling you
know you pay the people to keep your
lights your lectricity et cetera
you'd pay the most important people
first that you deem are the most
important companies are going to make
those decisions every day yeah they've
got all understand how much money
they've got and you've got to just have
a sensible conversation I think that
there will be some companies out there
that will go the final demand legal
route because they have no other options
and they've got so far down the line
it's that or nothing in there
in trouble the other extreme is starting
the conversation start having those part
payment conversations right yeah pop
Amy's better than no payment yeah I've
never say shion's and people would
appreciate as well if you're in the
position to be able to do that do you
know I mean it's you been empathetic
Sandler if it does help we can split
this over two months three months or
whatever if you can do that and a
hundred percent and have that
conversation we've talked about a few
times if you're the leader your job is
to get in the trenches with your people
and put those causing to customers you
can't rely on your consultant no matter
how experienced you go
please give me the money cuz my bosses
after me yeah yeah so being all things
well it's a great great question coming
from from Rob Hana and enforcing this so
what what do you think recruiters
business owners in the current climate
should not be doing to preserve their
authentic personal brand on and offline
what do we think about that good
question yeah cuz I think I don't know I
would say I would say just not what
everyone else is doing I don't know but
I just think I've never seen LinkedIn
busier at the moment with pictures of
people for tops so I think my best
advice would be if you're gonna do
something make it interesting you know
make it a value to someone know
everybody wants to just have a look at a
picture of your laptop when your desk at
home is brain in this good fun but you
know was it was it really add in yelling
yeah I think don't if the question is
what should you not be doing I would say
just don't roll over yes hon yeah
because I think from my perspective is
it's it's tough for me I've seen a lot
of them people obviously I'm empathize
because they're in a difficult situation
but people who have had to be let go for
whatever reason and the lot is quick
easy to point the finger at leaders and
say they've they banished me very
quickly or they made a contract decision
straight away and I think obviously
works both ways about and I saw a lot of
that over the last couple of weeks of
unfortunate lot of people have been made
redundant but also a lot of people send
that a lot of leaders in the industry
just cut loads of people really quickly
think of them a chance and that's
obviously hard for you guys to make
decisions like that like I think it's
important to be empathetic towards you
guys have to make super difficult
decisions or the banking guy writes
you've given me some advice as well but
the key thing I would explain to
everyone as they come for this journey
and I think that question is a really
good one just remember at the end of
this the way I always look at is how do
you want to be remembered
yeah good great question grass I want to
be remembered as the chump who keeps
putting things out there fine but also
remember your personal integrity as well
so you know what if you're looking for a
job by all means it's okay to pull out
there but I would probably leave the
personal personal DG and stuff like that
offline yeah not in a public domain you
got remember once it's out there it's
out there you've got no control about
where he goes yeah and and I think that
I think I'm I think we were talking a
bit about this before Liam likes quite
loosely but I mean the squat like squats
prime example question now I think
operation in the right way where Scott
Evans unfortunately he's been put on
temporary lay but started recruitment
recently and he's thinking what happens
do add value to a company from home and
continue to develop as a consultant so
if you found yourself in a difficult
spot now where and you have been
obviously put on that temporary leave
what what could people what could
recruit be doing to obscure themselves
instead of one sure they can volunteer
and get involved at NHS and things like
that but like other no what could these
consultants do to continue the they stay
they can do it from that they can as a
real quickly some about it's all about
mindset
really yeah the way you've got to the
way you've got to look at it he's it's
an opportunity no the world we live in
now and the training resources that are
available to people are at home you know
10 years ago the things that can happen
now just wouldn't have been possible so
the way we've been talking about is keep
yourself master it you know man thanks
you can train but you can't play so you
know you could get called back off the
bench at any time and get back into the
game but you need to key self mat
straight and ready to go really make
solid color make sure you're looking
after yourself make sure you still you
know keep you in a bit of a routine
doing you exercise looking after your
mental health also up scary cell from
the so many training courses out there
that you can access online keep doing
all those as well yeah that's awesome at
really like eat yourself much fat that's
a great way to pull that what would
anything to add to that mat like what
would you be doing if you're a
consultant with fungus and position we
haven't put anyone in that position
without my plans to but I think one of
the things to a tease if people are off
they're not supposed to be working for
their employer yeah so you know they
can't be resourcing the copy talk to
people because the employer will get
themselves in trouble just to be clear
on that
well they can do with personal
developments so yeah totally agree with
everything we said earlier there's some
great books out there is some great
stuff online you know start reading that
sharing it read some good books get your
mental health in it in a good place I'd
say there's you can read about new and
emerging markets but in terms of market
mapping talking to these people then
it's going to be difficult to do you
know guys
HMRC breathing down your neck yeah yeah
sure so how how do we how do we see this
evolving in chaps obviously if we were
to have a a to predict this what do we
think how long do you think this is in
the going folks you know one knows but
what what are your soul thoughts on how
this is gonna plan out you V&S Emily on
this one crystal ball what what do we
think can happen should I go first yeah
yeah my gut feel on this is I think this
is gonna be like the recession of 2008
2010 so there was talk of a slowdown a
definition of a recession is to economic
for two causes economic slowdown I think
what we see these companies cut Dave I
think we've seen the economy fall off a
cliff I think people are gonna be
quarantine I don't think this is going
to be three weeks I think it's going to
be six words maybe a little bit longer
than that oh my god
and I think was going to be spend and
confidence and I think we're gonna peak
and come down a little bit and come out
of it again that's my gut feel so I just
think it's going to be slow steady
investment I think if you're a
recruitment owner and the sun is shining
in three months and it feels confidence
don't go all out and just hire a ton of
people because let you steadily see what
happens that's my gut feel Stoli see
what happened there I would say my I
think we're in this for two months of
lockdown yeah tough times I think we're
probably gonna see four maybe six months
of slower growth or flatline maybe Liam
what do you think yeah agree with Matt
F&E on the and the downside I'd love to
think it's gonna be three weeks but
essentially it probably will be a bit
longer than that for all of us so but
perhaps slightly more optimistic on the
upside I think no having gone through in
2008 as well that there were a lot of
underlying economic conditions that led
to that collapse you know the the
underlying economy we're still under
strong and the demand will still be
there so you know particularly in the
infrastructure sectors that we work in
you know those projects are all they
still need to be built and the demand is
still there so I'm slightly more
optimistic about a bit of a bigger
bounce on the on the upswing when it
does get nice like that kalpesh so I
think we're in okay the optimist in me
says you know what hopefully we'll start
seeing some shoots moving forwards by
the end of May ish you know hopefully
but I think the realistic thing is only
seeing I don't want to be the guy that
burst everyone's bubble but you have to
be prepared to say this is the long haul
and I you know I think we were talking
about and we looked at something on the
visual capitalist it's great website if
you anyone wants to do some research on
crafts but you've got a v-shaped balance
you've got a u-shaped bounce and an S
shape and I actually think we learn with
math this could be a double dip in terms
of where we're going with this but be
cautious but also be optimistic and
being optimistic means looking where you
can pivot your business to still keep
growing
alright doesn't mean there are 150
people what it does mean is where where
were the opportunities with your
customers where are the opportunities in
your markets right but also torture
people because then you know your people
are out there talking to number of
people in their networks where are they
finding opportunities
yeah and that was gonna be I just wanted
to sort of do before we finish chaps is
light and obviously you guys have been
through this and and and built towards
obviously bouncing back so that how
would what the for some sort of people
were approaching building or coming to
the bounce to get ready for hopefully
what will be a great upside and sort of
yeah get back to normal whatever but how
should people be best preparing for the
bounce back do you think so I'm gonna
say this one if that's okay my first
thing is before you worry about the
external world onus still something from
Matt is all about make sure you're ready
yeah that's physical whether it's mental
whether you're doing a job XP but you've
got to look after yourself because you
don't know when they'll be needs any
comfort so look off your mental health
yeah twelve then the second part of it
is just on PCP understanding what's
going on with your market read the press
read the paper look at opportunities
look at what industries are starting to
talk about good stuff you know there's
so much information out there yeah
course them go watch the fade news but
there are some good stuffs can we look
around the world where if there's any
economies further down the line than we
are
then look at what's going on in those
countries where are the opportunities
coming through alright okay I think the
two things yet you can look off yourself
number one you've got be match fit and
the second thing is just start looking
at opportunities around the world and go
right how does that relate to what we're
doing here and then the final one is if
you stay close to your customers your
customers will tell you when they're
ready yeah okay Matt anything to add I
look what kalpesh said their focus on us
firstly it sounds selfish but we've got
to understand as as the business owners
the leaders the managers whatever what
we want it might be growth but we might
not want a 500 million pound turnover
business what why do we want it
and how we're gonna go about doing that
and I think once that's in place for me
the next most important thing is the
existing people that we've got so are
they happy that probably just come out
of it they'll have come out of a war you
know really have time so let's get let's
invest in those guys firstly yeah make
sure that happy and then we look at how
we further business yeah and I so really
focusing yeah I like that
Lynn what about you what are you
thinking about you know brilliant from
brilliant advice from these guys always
a big believe them you know again bit
selfish but pick your own oxygen mask on
first yeah I'm trying to be help
everyone else and you know I've been a
victim of that before and you know if
you're not match for yourself for
everyone else is going to see that and
everything else is going to get the
knock-on effect from it so yeah looking
after yourself definitely key and going
back to what kalpesh said as well I
think different areas of the world are
kind of going to come out of this at
different times so that will naturally
create opportunity you know befitting
here and make sure you're ready to take
advantage of those opportunities no
matter where they are in the globe the
world's a small place now so you know
don't don't limit your aizen's at all
yeah great point cool well honestly guys
thank you and so much for your time I
think I hope you had a lot to think a
lot of people got value out this if
anyone again just really open to
people's feedback how you finding this
hopefully you all found it really useful
and thank you for giving us your time on
this sunny afternoon we really
appreciate it
but if anyone does want to reach out or
asking a question or anything you guys
happy for people to reach out and just
drop you know that best place on
LinkedIn okay cool all right well um
look yeah thank you guys for your time
chaps and thanks have run for tuning in